big news breaking last night Paul
Manafort plea deal with prosecutors has
been voided by a judge and this has
massive implications not just that Paul
Manafort may now be spending the rest of
his life in prison which I'll get to in
a second but implications as far as the
investigation at large let's sort of
reset a little bit Paul Manafort was
Donald Trump's campaign chairman he had
made a plea deal with prosecutors he was
convicted of various financial crimes in
August in September we learned about
this plea deal for guilty charges of
conspiracy and witness tampering and the
way that those deals work is you agree
to cooperate with prosecutors and tell
them the truth of course that helps them
to make other cases bigger cases ideally
and in exchange prosecutors give you a
reduction in charges that you have to
plead to and/or a reduction in the
sentence that is recommended to the
judge in the sentencing sentencing phase
there were suspicions that Paul Manafort
was lying to prosecutors and
investigators even after he had made
this cooperation agreement which means
he had agreed to tell the truth and a
federal judge
Amy Berman Jackson has now decided that
yes Paul Manafort
lied multiple times knowingly to the FBI
to Robert Muller's office and to the
grand jury that was involved their lied
about legal bills
lied about interactions with Russians
while he was Trump's campaign chairman
and these were lies that weren't
insignificant these were what are called
material lies with regard to the
investigation this is what's incredible
about these circumstances because
Manafort lied he now loses the benefits
of the plea deal meaning the reduced
sentence but he's still bound by what he
agreed to in the police so he can't now
say okay I no longer get the reduced
sentence so I want to retract those
guilty pleas and fight this thing those
guilty pleas that were part of it remain
mana forts lawyers are saying well he
said things that weren't true but he
didn't intentionally lie the judge
disagrees and judge
Jackson is going to be sentencing mana
for next month for two conspiracy counts
and then there's the sentencing for
eight counts related to a fraud case so
let's just look at the numbers Paul
Manafort turns 70 years old on April
Fool's Day in a couple of months he was
going to get sentenced to 8 to 10 years
based on the plea deal with good
behavior maybe it ends up being five or
six and by the time he's 76 years old
he's back out in the free world now he
is potentially facing 30 years in prison
with good behavior you're still looking
at being more like in your late 80s or
early 90s and with mana Ford's health
reportedly not great this could turn
into a life sentence for Paul Manafort
as a result of the lies that he told so
this isn't good for him it's nothing to
laugh at but this is serious stuff he
does have one possible way out and that
would be a pardon from President Trump
but even there there are some issues for
mana for number one we haven't even
started with possible state crimes that
could be brought against Paul Manafort
everything's been federal so far and the
presidential pardon power only extends
to federal charges if it if ultimately
there are state charges Donald Trump's
not going to be able to help Paul
Manafort there but the biggest impact of
this is actually on the broader probe
because when you look into what it is
that mana fort lied about one of the
things mana fort continued to lie about
even after he made this plea deal is
about his contacts his meetings with
russian intelligence officer konstantin
Killam Nick
why would mana for lie about that even
after this deal and the the obvious
speculation is because the truth of
those meetings is so damning not just to
mana fort but to so many other people in
Trump's inner circle we know that mana
fort met with Russian intelligence
officer Killam Nick he knew that he was
meeting with a Russian intelligence
officer the meeting was during the
campaign while mana fort was Trump's
campaign chairman and when they met they
talked about a plan to split up you
train and to remove US sanctions both in
a way that would be hugely beneficial to
Russia we also know that manna forgave
Killam Nick internal campaign data at a
time when he knew that Russia was
actively engaged in trying to get Donald
Trump elected and lastly we know that
Killam Nick was fun funneling money to
the Trump campaign through a Republican
operative named Sam Patton so the
implications of this are absolutely
enormous the proof is that Manafort
continued to lie about it even after he
made a plea deal not to lie you only do
that if something is really really wrong
with you but manna fort has competent
counsel and it's hard to imagine they
were advising him to keep lying or
because you've calculated that the risk
to yourself of lying to investigators
even after making the plea deal is not
as great as simply telling the truth
about the meetings and interactions that
you had with this known Russian
intelligence officer Konstantin Killam
Nick will know more about manna Ford
sentencing next month and hopefully will
soon know more about the content of his
lies as well I am thrilled to tell you
that today's episode is sponsored in
part by Blink asam / Pakman blinka is a
really unique service for your phone
tablet and web browser and it is
incredibly useful for people like me who
love books and learning but are busy
blinka steaks the best and most popular
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks I'm sure that
if you're like me you have a very long
list of books that you've been meaning
to read you only have so many hours in
the day and that's why blink astiz so
amazing they take the most important
information the themes the insights from
each book and they distill it into a 15
minute audio book that you can listen to
in one sitting I've listened to a ton of
books on blankets
our audience can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on YouTube
I've put a link
in the description I have listened to
blinka spokes about economics about
political science about history about
science so many interesting things and
after the free trial if you like it you
can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about 5 bucks a
month go to blink is calm slash Pakman
that's be Li NK is t.com /pa k ma n